so berlin kuba illinois das hier sind
beziehungsweise waren drei gebäude die
alle etwas gemeinsam haben
sie alle folgen dem gleichen vorbild
eines perfekten gefängnisses ein vorbild
das sich gleichzeitig auch auf
arbeitsplätze psychiatrie und sogar
schulen übertragen lassen sollen warum
ist das wichtig wenn wir uns diese
bilder genau anschauen dann können wir
verstehen wie unsere gesellschaft bald
funktionieren könnte und es teilweise
auch heute schon tut heute geht es
überwachung es geht um angst und wie man
es schafft dass sich milliarden menschen
ganz freiwillig selbst zensieren
[Musik]
bevor wir mit ihm eigentlich wieder
loslegen jetzt wahrscheinlich schon
gesehen wir haben wir neues merge
gedroppt hier schon mal ein sample davon
ich finde es sehr nass geworden ihr habt
noch zwei wochen zeit diese t-shirts und
bestellen bis zum 31 august aber
vielleicht wartet ihr noch eine woche ab
denn wenn ihr pageid oder noch kathrin
werden wollt am 21 august verlosen unter
allen pagewizz fünf dieser t shirts hier
und wenn ja nicht auf ihr glück
angewiesen sein wollt dann könnt ihr
auch ihren doktor oder professor werden
und bekommt auch automatisch eines
dieser t shirts hier von uns geschenkt
wir schreiben euch dann an welche größe
wir haben wollte und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit dem video also woher kommen
diese runden gefängnis sie hier das
alles geht zurück auf einen der
bekanntesten philosophen jeremy bentham
das neunzehnte jahrhundert war vor allem
die zeit von riesigen fabriken mit
bisher undenkbar vielen arbeitenden
damit das management der fabriken besser
läuft wurde bentley beauftragt die
perfekte fabrik zu designen die aufgabe
minimales management aber maximale
kontrolle und damit hat eine idee ihren
lauf genommen am ende stand mit
bauplänen da die nicht nur den perfekten
arbeitsplatz sondern auch das perfekte
gefängnis die perfekte schule oder die
perfekte psychiatrie sein sollten das
war die geburtsstunde vom sogenannten
panoptikum
das panoptikum ist als gefängnis sind
zellen im kreis angeordnet ist zwischen
den zellen gibt es keine fenster die
gefangenen sind also isoliert
voneinander sie können nur nach vorne in
die mitte des gebäudes schauen und in
der mitte ist dieser tour dort sitzen
die gefängniswärter oder vielleicht
sogar auch nur einmal dazu aber gleich
mehr die gefängniswärter können aus dem
turm in die zellen sehen die gefangenen
können aber nicht in den turm sehen
entweder wegen verspiegeltem glas oder
weil dort mit grellen scheinwerfern auf
die schienen wird ergo keiner der
insassen kann wissen was die anderen
insassen und die wörter in der mitte
gerade tun sagen wir also ich bin
irgendwie einen optischen gefängnis
gelandet vielleicht habe ich ja
vergessen meine quellen anzugeben und
bin im youtube gefängnis für
wissenschafts youtuber gelandet und ich
sitze also in meiner zelle und kann mir
zum keinen zeiten sicher sein auf die
wörter gerade in meine zelle gucken oder
in eine der hundert anderen zellen ich
weiß nicht mal ob wir gerade im turm
sind aber ich muss davon ausgehen so
gute idee auch an kam das erste
panoptikum gefängnis wurde eingestampft
und dann ist das konzept erst mal in der
versenkung verschwunden bis es einer der
brillantesten philosophen der letzten
100 jahre wieder aus dem schrank und
anstatt als bauplan hat michelle
foucault das panoptikum als ein modell
verstanden das panoptikum zeigt die
moderne westliche gesellschaft und ihre
machtstrukturen ganz vereinfacht gesagt
unsere gesellschaft ist ein riesiges
panoptikum in einem panoptikum kann ich
mir nie sicher sein ob ich gerade
überwacht werde oder nicht das risiko
dass sich die wachen oder der staat
gerade meine zelle oder mein leben
genauer anschauen kann ich nie
ausschließen
ich werde gesehen aber kann selber nicht
sehen in der praxis sollte diese
architektur des gefängnisses oder etwas
abstrakter 1 1 gesellschaft also dazu
führen dass ich selber anfangen nach den
regeln zu spielen ohne dass man mich
wiederholt kontrollieren oder darauf
hinweisen muss aber klar zwischen einem
gefängnis und einer modernen
gesellschaft gibt es ein paar
offensichtliche unterschiede ich kann
meine wohnung jederzeit verlassen und
ein riesiger turm beobachtet mich ja
auch nicht der grund warum sie die heute
so relevant ist wird vor allem deutlich
wenn wir uns anschauen wie
fortgeschrittenen technologien zwischen
ist und wie sehr kameras mikrofone und
gps tracking unser leben bestimmen jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen bei uns wir
noch total egal wer meine daten hat und
ich habe ja eh nichts zu verbergen
deswegen wird der staat mich ja schon
nicht anzapfen das verändert also mein
verhalten überhaupt nicht aber genau das
ist ja das perfide daran das weißt du
nicht dass du dein ganzes leben
vielleicht schon in einem panoptikum
gelebt hast in dem du überwacht werden
kannst weißt du gar nicht wie du dich
verhalten
du bist wenn du wirklich komplett frei
davon wärs denn durch pan optische
strukturen passieren zwei sehr spannende
dinge erstens macht und ordnung laufen
quasi von allein und zweitens macht wird
die individualisiert macht wird also
automatisch ausgeübt und es ist egal von
wem es ist im prinzip irrelevant ob
gerade ein wachmann im turm willst oder
nicht da ich immer davon ausgehen muss
dass einer da ist ein panoptikum ist die
perfekte macht bis auch die architektur
braucht es quasi nichts laut fico ist
das panoptikum die logische konsequenz
der vergangenheit dadurch dass
gesellschaften stark gewachsen sind hat
sich das panoptikum als
gesellschaftliche struktur quasi selber
notwendig gemacht früher zum beispiel im
fall der im mittelalter waren starten
oder ihr gesellschaften sehr viel
kleiner als heute ordnung hat damals
durch direkte kontrolle und körperliche
bestrafung funktioniert heute sind
starten aber mit anderen größenordnungen
konfrontiert ein land kann unmöglich 80
300 oder 900 millionen menschen direkt
kontrollieren und im fall der fälle
bestrafen deswegen sagt fokko dass wir
von einer strafgesetz schafft zu einer
disziplin gesellschaft geworden sind und
disziplin verinnerlichen menschen eben
sehr gut wenn sich niemand jemals sicher
sein kann ob er oder sie gerade
beobachtet wird es entsteht soziale
kontrolle ausgeübt von jedem einzelnen
alleine ohne dass der staat mir
persönlich auf die finger gucken muss es
reicht die möglichkeit dass er es gerade
tut aus gewaltsamer kontrolle wurde also
selbstkontrolle und die ist viel
günstiger und effektiver
ich finde das alles sehr spannend und
eigentlich auch ziemlich einleuchtend
trotzdem muss das an dieser stelle erst
mal gesagt werden ob wir wirklich jetzt
schon in einem von opticon leben oder es
bald tun werden das ist eine große
debatte wo sich noch viele leute uneinig
sind ein beispiel das da gerne
diskutiert wird ist china nur wenige
staaten haben eine so flächendeckende
überwachung wie china von den weltweit
zwölf städten mit den meisten
überwachungskameras neben neuen in china
und china wird auch die weltrangliste an
wenn es um die stadt mit den meisten
kameras pro 1000 einwohnern geht das
social credit system ein komplett
abgeriegelt das internet und das skynet
sind nur ein paar puzzlestücke in einem
riesigen netzwerk von überwachungs und
kontrollsysteme und dieses netzwerk
schaut auf 1,4 milliarden menschen
klingt dann ja erst mal logisch dass da
zumindest ein teil der macht und
kontrolle automatisiert werden muss und
was da schon mal zutrifft ist was
foucault den games zu deutsch den blick
nimmt also gesehen werden aber selber
nicht sehen können china zum beispiel
das skelett oder das berühmt berüchtigte
social credit system anstelle eines
gefängnisses folgsamer insassen könnte
man sagen dass china eine ganze klasse
wirksamer bürger erzielt so argumentiert
zumindest eine seite wenn wir uns das in
europa anschauen gibt es da schon
ähnlichkeiten auch wenn die überwachung
natürlich nicht auf dem selben level ist
wie in china england hat zumindest in
den städten flächendeckende
videoüberwachung auf deutschen
autobahnen filme nicht verkehrs kameras
und dank des aktuellen polizeigesetzes
nrw dürfen menschen vorsorglich
digitalen überwacht werden wenn konkrete
wahrscheinlichkeit besteht dass sie eine
terroristische straftat begehen
gleichzeitig gebe ich privaten firmen
die metapher wert und apple freiwillig
meine daten lasse mich von algorithmen
beobachten und bewerten und bin mir
bewusst dass mein verhalten zur
optimierung von werbung getrackt wird
das erzeugt zumindest bei menschen die
sich damit beschäftigen natürlich ein
gefühl der potenziellen transparenz ich
könnte jetzt gerade digital
durchleuchtet werden oder von einer
öffentlichen kamera oder meiner
handykamera gefilmt werden solange diese
gefahr besteht verhalte ich mich anders
vermutlich gehorsamer als wenn ich nicht
unbeobachtet fühlen würde und das klingt
nach von opticon die große frage wenn
wir beantworten wollen ob das panoptikum
hier oder sonst wo schon da ist hat
etwas mit der form der überwachung zu
tun aber viel wichtiger um das zu
bewerten ist es sich anzuschauen ob es
funktioniert also haben wir jetzt schon
eine form der selbst kontrolle erreicht
hier sind sich philosophen und
analytiker uneinig unsere jetzige
überwachung ist dezentralisiert im
paneuropäischen gefängnis gibt es aber
eine zentrale stelle der überwachung von
der die insassen wissen in unserer
gesellschaft oder in anderen
gesellschaften mit einem ausgeprägten
überwachungsapparat ist das aber nicht
so wir wussten beispielsweise ganz lange
nicht wie weitreichend das prison
programm der us-regierung und und zum
beispiel auch den damaligen
bundeskanzlerin auf die finger schaut
dass das silicon valley daten sammelt
war vielen bewusst ja das ausmaß wurde
fielen aber auch erst mit dem cambridge
analytiker skandal klar hier handelt es
sich aber natürlich nicht um einen staat
sondern um private
wirtschaftsunternehmen was die
panoptikum diskussion noch einmal
verkompliziert aber eines bleibt gleich
ohne den effekt dass ich weiß dass man
mich gerade beobachten könnte bleibt
auch die gewünschte selbstkontrolle des
panoptikums aus bis jetzt und wenn wir
in deutschland bleiben kann man ziemlich
leicht sehen dass es möglich ist den
blick der regierung fernzubleiben und
kritisch zu sein ohne strafe zu fürchten
auch china ist noch keine lupenreines
panoptikum in der landes müssen
kritischen journalisten aufpassen anteil
der überwachungs struktur lässt sich
dort aber auch durch vpns umgehen wenn
man in deutschland aber auch in china
also schlupflöcher finden und widerstand
leisten kann verhindert dass dann das
panoptikum nein nach buckow ist absolute
kontrolle und disziplin sowie so
unerreichbar auch im perfekten gefängnis
wird es auf ständige geben nach focus
ist moderne macht lange keine zentrale
einheit mehr sondern ein netzwerk und wo
in einem netzwerk macht ist ist auch
widerstand das ist der natürliche lauf
der dinge
also egal ob jetzt definitiv im fokus
panoptikum leben leben werden oder dass
wir immer eine dystopie bleibt das
panoptikum ist ein sehr spannendes
konzept um zu verstehen wie die
überwachung kontrolle und
disziplinierung von riesigen massen
funktionieren kann
gleichzeitig ist es aber auch eine gute
erinnerung daran dass kontrolle und die
sich ausweitende überwachung dann
schleichender prozess sind viele kleine
gesetz und prozesse über lange zeit
bauen womöglich jetzt gerade ein
panoptikum in dem jeder gesehen werden
kann aber niemand sieht da stellt sich
natürlich die frage ist das jetzt gut
oder schlecht ich finde das erstmal sehr
beunruhigend und das muss ja jeder für
sich selber entscheiden also wollen wir
in so einer gesellschaft leben geht es
vielleicht gar nicht anders mit so
vielen menschen auf dieser erde ich
freue mich darauf mit euch in den
kommentaren zu diskutieren bleibt die
man
neugierig